logarithms and exponents are pretty
closely related what is 3 to the power 4
it is 3 times 3 times 3 times 3 but will
equal 81 so the power of the base tells
us how many times the base is multiplied
with itself we say that 3 raise to 4
equals 81 we have studied this in
exponents what a logarithm cell now this
exact same thing can be written using
logarithms this can be written as
logarithm of 81 to the base 3 is equal
to 4
yes logarithm can also be written as log
but look at this expression carefully
the power or the exponent is the answer
and the base of the log is the base
number so when the log expression we are
asking 3 raised to what will give us 81
3 raised to 4 the power to which the
base of the log needs to be raised to to
get the argument will be the answer the
power to which 3 needs to be raised to
to get 81 will be the answer it's 4
wasn't that simple let's look at an
interesting problem log of 125 to the
base 5 is given to us as X what is the
value of x to get the answer we should
try writing this in the exponential form
this asks us 5 raised to what power
gives us 125 5 to the power x gives us
125 this makes it easier to find the
value of x we know that 5 times 5 times
5 is 125 so 5 to the power 3 will equal
125 it gives us the value of x as 3
let me give you two more examples I want
you to pause the video and find the
values x and y so how did you write the
first equation in exponential form to
raise to what gives us 32 2 raised to
the power x gives us 32 and we know that
2 raised to 5 equals 32 the value of x
is 5 the second one is bit interesting
the equation can be written as 4 raised
to y is equal to 1 4 to what power will
result in 1 do you remember a property
of exponents any nonzero number raised
to 0 will result in 1 hence 4 raised to
0 will equal 1 the value of y is 0
you